in regards to the extreme gas when eating greens, what is the best enzyme to take?
I would do the the HClsign. These greens also have carbohydrates in them. So digestive enzymes,
any digestive enzymes in themselves really are working in this small and large intestine
and do most of their work of proteins and fats, if there's light paste in there too.
And you know, there's some digestive enzymes that also work on carbohydrates.
Your body, they're secreted in your product glands.
But in your stomach, you have HCl that's secreted. You don't secret any enzymes in your stomach.
HCl is secreted in your stomach and many times it's an HCl deficiency.
That is probably the most common deficiency across the board
is an HCl deficiency because of our diets. Our stomach doesn't produce as much HCl as it should.
And we eat way more calories than we should. And we end up with deficiency in HCl. So if you have
any issues with carbohydrates, it really should be the HClsign. If it solely proteins that you have
issues with, then you could just take digestive enzymes. Reason why I like HClsign is that HCl plus digestive
enzymes in it, plus our so does our clear digest. That's why we private label that. I can't private
label any of the U.S. enzyme products right now. They're just too small of a company. Let me do that.
The clear digest that we that we private label from sides for health is got HCl and all these enzymes
in it as well. And as far as dosing them as far as with the gas, you have to dose these.
So you start with taking one per meal, okay? And well, you know, that's not helping. And I'd give
it a week. That's not helping. Then you go to two per meal. That's still not helping. Give it a
week, maybe three, four, five days, okay? And then you go to three per meal. And I've had people have
to get up to seven or eight per meal. And finally, it takes away their issues. And then you start to
titrate down. So you get up to seven or eight a meal in filings. It's really, really helping. And then,
you know, then you can start, well, I got to just take six now. I'm going to take five. Now it
is going to take, and it's really dependent upon the size of the meal, too. So if you're just eating
something small, you might not take eight. So that's how you're going to play with that dosage. And then
you're basically giving your stomach and your, your, your bakery or some break by taking those.
And then you can slowly titrate down. I know I'm getting that problem back at one. I'm going to go back
up to two. You find what's perfect for you.